I wasn't aware there was a third person in my marriage.
But please tell me again
how you know for a fact everything is his.
Know for a fact that I don't have a job.
And know for a fact that I don't have any job.
Anything his name is on,
my name is also on.
I don't technically have a typical 9 to 5,
but, you know,
what I do have is some side hustles.
I know I'm not naive to think enough
that a side hustle is going to sustain me
if my husband would ever leave, not when.
And I do have multiple skills and jobs in my past
that I always use.
Think. I don't care if you say this kind of thing
of make sure you have a backup plan
or when he leaves you,
as long as we're saying the same thing to career women,
because career women can also be left.
They can also lose jobs.
They can also have the worst thing
possible happen to them in their lives,
and they'd still be okay,
because women are resilient.
Feminism is just not about choice,
and it's never been about choice.
So let's stop pretending feminism's about choice,
because y'all act like this.
That choice feminism,
and it's never been about choice,
and it never will be about choice.